learn to architect and develop Android
apps in the Kotlin programming language
using industry proven tools and
libraries creating Android apps in
Kotlin is of course developed by Google
together with Udacity you'll learn by
building real Android apps using
industry best practices with modern app
architecture understand why and how to
use Android jetpack components such as a
room for databases work manager for
background processing the new navigation
component and more you'll use key Kotlin
features to write your app code more
quickly and concisely learning to
develop on Android is much more than
learning api's and shortcuts it's
training your brain to think like a
mobile developer come learn with us for
more information on this free course and
to see all of googles courses with
Udacity go to udacity.com/google